Hola mi nombre es Emma, un en el video de hoy voy a enseñarte algunas expresiones clave.
Puedes usar cuando alguien te dice algo que no es
verdad y quieres discutir en contra de lo que están diciendo.
Así que, en este video te voy a enseñar estas
grandes expresiones.
Pero antes de hacer eso.
Vamos a hablar de 3 palabras que son muy
comunes en Inglés.
En estos días, esas 3 palabras son falsas teorías de la conspiración de noticias
y el engaño es así que en este video usted aprenderá
lo que estas palabras significan?
Y usted también aprenderá qué decirle a alguien
que le dice algo que no es cierto.
Muy bien, así que vamos a empezar.
Así que tengo aquí 3 frase es la primera frase
es los científicos dicen que la Tierra es plana,
no redonda. ¿Es esto cierto o no es cierto?
OK, esta frase no es verdad algunas personas creen esto
pero no es cierto.
Mi segunda frase Michael Jackson está vivo y viviendo como
Kim Kardashian.
Verdadero o no cierto.
Una vez más, tenemos una frase que no es verdad.
Lo inventé.
Y finalmente mi tercera frase escuchando música rock causa
cáncer es esto verdadero o falso.
Una vez más, esto es falso. También lo inventé así que mi punto aquí es que mucho de lo que escuchas de la gente en conversación no es cierto.
La gente dice, este tipo de cosas todo el tiempo y
sabrás que esto es algo que no es cierto. que Michael
Jackson está viviendo como Kim Kardashian,
así que voy a enseñarte esas grandes expresiones que puedes
Antes de hacer que quería decir que
estas 3 frases también se puede considerar noticias falsas.
Así que vamos a ver el significado de noticias falsas
en un momento.
OK por lo que el 3 principal palabras,
Quería enseñarte hoy son palabras que
verá mucho en Internet y en los
medios de comunicación.
La primera palabra es noticias falsas Así que lo que es falsa
noticias mientras que falso significa no es cierto?
Las noticias falsas son historias de noticias que no son verdaderas y
su creado para dañar a una persona,
un negocio. Una agencia o gobierno o también podrían
ser creados para llamar la atención y para obtener clics en
la Internet.
Así que usted verá un montón de noticias falsas en diferentes
redes sociales como Twitter,
Facebook y un montón de otros lugares en línea.
Así que esta es una palabra muy común en estos días mucho
de la gente es usándolo.
Así que es importante que sepas lo que significa.
También tenemos la palabra aquí,
teoría de la conspiración. Así que una teoría de la conspiración. ¿Es una explicación? De un evento o situación que es
diferente de la cuenta oficial muchas de la conspiración del Times
teorías son sobre el gobierno o un negocio haciendo algo ilegal
o para dañar a alguien así que vamos a pensar en algunas teorías conspirativas
Algunas personas creen que el aterrizaje de la luna.
Entonces cuando cuando astronautas fueron a la luna en la
1960.
Algunas personas creen que el aterrizaje de la luna era falso.
Esta es una teoría popular de la conspiración.
Otra teoría de la conspiración, escuché recientemente es que algunas personas creen
que Paul McCartney de The Beatles realmente murió en 1966
y hay un hombre diferente que lo reemplazó y
que es en realidad el mejor músico por lo que esta es una
diferente teoría de la conspiración.
Así que verás un montón de teorías conspirativas en el
Y mucha gente te dirá teorías conspirativas
engaño.
Engaño tan un engaño. ¿Cómo cubriría el gobierno eso o cómo la música rock and roll causaría cáncer para que siempre puedas hacer estas preguntas?
¿Por qué y cómo un usted sabe,
tal vez tienen una buena explicación.
Pero es bueno hacer estas preguntas para averiguar
más acerca de por qué piensan lo que piensan.
También puede contrarrestar lo que están diciendo significado si
decir algo,
y usted no está de acuerdo usted puede decir su opinión para
ejemplo.
Si alguien te dijo que Kim Kardashian es realmente Michael
Jackson.
Puedes decir que el hecho del asunto es que Michael
Jackson falleció.
Él no es Kim Kardashian.
La verdad es Michael Jackson y Kim Kardashian o no
la misma persona.
También puedes decir en realidad.
Michael Jackson no es Kim Kardashian.
Así que estas son grandes expresiones,
puedes usar cuando estás tratando de decirle a alguien que
lo que están diciendo es incorrecto y que lo que estás diciendo
es la creencia correcta.
Bien, hemos repasado todas estas cosas diferentes para
usted algo que no es cierto, así que vamos
practicarlo.
Ok, esto sólo en noticias falsas.
¿Escuchaste que los terroristas han derretido la Antártida usando un gigante
láser OK,
Así que los terroristas han derretido la Antártida usando un láser gigante? Así que esa es la noticia, que acabo de inventar. Son noticias falsas. Entonces, tu fuente es Emma.
Y esta no es una buena fuente para esta noticia
Entonces, ¿qué puedes decirme si te doy
una noticia falsa como esa? O tal vez digas que eso no es cierto que podrías decir... ¿dónde oíste a Emma? ¿Por qué los terroristas derretirían la Antártida con un láser gigante?
¿Cómo conseguirían los terroristas el láser para que pudieran hacer
estas preguntas y luego podría decirme la verdad.
El hecho del asunto es que un Arctica no ha sido derretido por terroristas que son noticias falsas.
Así que gracias por ver Espero que hayas aprendido algo
tal vez sobre algunas de estas palabras como falso engaño de noticias
o teoría de la conspiración.
También, tal vez algunas expresiones que puedes usar cuando escuchas
algo que es falso.
Me gustaría invitarte a venir a ver nuestro
sitio web en WWW dotindeed.com.
En realidad puedes hacer un cuestionario para practicar lo que
aprendes en este video.
También lo haría me gusta invitarte a suscribirse a
mi canal.
Usted puede encontrar una gran cantidad de otros recursos está en
muchas cosas diferentes sobre Inglés,
incluyendo Inglés expresiones de conversación vocabulario trabajo Inglés y mucho
más.
Gracias por ver un hasta la próxima vez tener cuidado.
.